the general affairs council has paved
the way for a summit this week of eu
leaders in brussels where climate and
energy will top the agenda
a main objective of the summit the
european council is to reach agreement
on the outlines of the eu's climate and
energy policy through to the year 2030
the union stands at the forefront of
international efforts to combat global
warming
the policy addresses greenhouse gas
emissions targets the state of the
emissions trading system energy
efficiency renewable energy sources and
energy security
the tone of the discussion was uh was
very encouraging
there is a
there remain uh
the um
the will to reach an ambitious position
of the european union and the need also
to take to tackle with realism some
issues which are still
outstanding
during the summit the leaders will also
discuss the state of the european
economy and debate issues of
international concern like the ebola
crisis
in other developments at the general
affairs council in luxembourg the
ministers exchange views on justice and
security issues including irregular
migration terrorism foreign fighters
asylum policy and data protection
you